nato says it does not seek war but is
ready for it its foreign ministers have
met to discuss the conflict in ukraine
but will the alliance get involved and
if it does what will be the consequences
this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
daddy nabogeta the russian invasion of
ukraine is now in its second week and
there's no sign of a let up friday saw
the attack on europe's largest nuclear
facility by russian forces in ukraine
the site caught fire before being put
out it sparked worldwide condemnation
and fears of a catastrophic radiation
leak
nato foreign ministers have met in
brussels for a special summit on ukraine
the alliance has imposed more sanctions
on the russian leader vladimir putin and
his inner circle and the u.s is going
after business leaders who are closely
tied to the kremlin
but none of this appears to be swaying
putin into pulling back his troops the
u.s secretary of state anthony blinken
says nato does not want confrontation
with moscow but it stands ready if
conflict comes
while the head of the alliance condemned
russia's attack on the nuclear sites as
we reckless the attacks on
civilians and overnight we're also
seeing reports about
the attack against nuclear power this
just demonstrates the
recklessness of this war and the
importance of
ending it and the importance of russia
withdrawing all its troops
and engaging good faith in diplomatic
efforts
every
ally
in one way or another is coming to
ukraine's assistance every ally in one
way or another is helping uh to
strengthen nato itself
and as the secretary general said ours
is a defensive alliance
we seek no conflict but if conflict
comes to us
we're ready for it and we will defend
every inch of nato territory
we'll bring in our guests in a moment
but first let's look at why ukraine has
long been a particularly sensitive issue
for moscow it was part of the russian
empire before becoming a soviet republic
and then winning independence in 1991
when the soviet union collapsed moscow
has since been concerned with keeping
ukraine out of nato vladimir putin says
the west promised in the past nato
wouldn't expand eastwards but since 1997
14 more countries have joined the
alliance mainly in the east
there were tensions eight years ago when
mass protests toppled the ukrainian
president viktor yanukovich he'd pushed
for closer ties to moscow rather than
the eu
russia's armed forces responded by
annexing the crimean peninsula and
backing a separatist rebellion in
eastern ukraine
let's not bring in our guests joining us
from brussels is brooks tigner who's the
correspondent for jane's defense weekly
magazine in washington d.c robert hunter
a former u.s ambassador to nato joining
us from moscow andre baklanov who's the
chairman of the board of the association
of russian diplomats thank you so much
for your time with us on inside story
ambassador robert over to you uh jen
stoltenberg has just said that nato is
not part of the conflict nato is a
defensive alliance we don't seek war or
conflict with russia but the longer this
goes on what does nato do then
the nato commitment
under article 5 of the treaty of
washington
is to defend
countries that are formerly members of
the alliance
and uh everybody in nato is trying to
get across to mr putin that whatever
happens in ukraine and i'm sure we're
going to be talking about that
uh he'd better not make any mistake
that is to put it
by the american secretary of state uh
any russians
coming into any nato countries
nato
including the united states is ready to
respond so it's going to be a very firm
defense of all nato islands if it comes
to that at the same time
while a number of nato countries are
providing weaponry to the ukrainians
nato no nato country is prepared to go
to war uh for ukraine which is not a
nato member all right um that brooks
over to you do you share the same point
of view as the ambassador does i mean
what does nato do if this continues uh
the war on ukraine we've we've seen all
sort of unprecedented reaction so far
including of course the sanctions on
russia as well as uh for the first time
the purchase and delivery
of weapons to ukraine itself
well yes i agree with robert said all
the way down the line on on the policy
and the article five issues
um if this
if russia continues its aggression um
and the threat perception increases on
nato's part what can it do well it has
to do more of what it's already done
which he effectively just described
both robert and the secretary general
but also i think
if they are going to help ukraine even
though they can't fly their jets there
and put any boots on the ground they
need to step up their weapons transfers
which are not necessarily very speedy uh
given they've got to go across land
primarily uh russia's blocking most of
the sea access
so indeed i just asked the second gen
this question in his press conference
you know you should need to consider
setting up a more permanent
uh structure for moving weapons of
coordinating bilateral transfers among
the weapons nato itself doesn't transfer
weapons of course but
the eu is doing this with poland it
seems to me it would make sense to at
least set up a standing ad hoc a
standing structure that's more than ad
hoc
either that rotates among the allies as
the coordinator or is coordinated by
nato
but the secretary general seemed to
suggest that's not on the table for the
time being since you're in that press
conference let me just um get one more
question to you brooks and that is the
uh calls by the ukrainian president i'm
sure you've heard for nato to enforce a
no-fly zone now this is something that
the secretary general has come out and
said
that is not going to happen he has ruled
out that idea the lithuanian prime
minister describing it as irresponsible
um
do you think that nato is going to stick
to this
he has to unless it wants war i mean to
set up a no-fly zone and enforce that
over the skies of ukraine would put
allied uh troops and equipment and
weapons directly in conflict with those
of russia and that would be war so
simple answer no
all right andre uh over in moscow over
the last weeks we
um
this is according to to nato in fact uh
what they're saying is that they have
increased their presence in the eastern
part of the alliance and for the first
time they are deploying the nato
response force with french troops now
arriving in romania this is quite
unprecedented
with nato building up its military how
is this being perceived by the kremlin
actually there is nothing special in
these facts because
this is the prolongation of the many
years of the
nether policy
they are bringing closer and closer
their military infrastructure to our
territory there were 14
members of the block now they are having
30
members of the of the block and
officially if we started the documents
of nato they officially are attributing
uh
the
word enemy to us
so well actually
what we have uh
now for
for the
more than 20 years nato is coming closer
and closer to our
to our cities to our centers of
industrial might this is very dangerous
we remember the lessons of 1941
when hitler uh attacked us
and we are not going to make the same
mistakes as we did
before the second world war when we were
very cautious
not to start war not to uh but we were
trying to to to do our utmost not to
have war but it was in vain
and uh now we are warning the west not
to come closer uh and closer to us this
is too dangerous to ourselves and we
will defend ourselves which we already
started in the process of denudification
of of ukraine we are calling this
liberation mean proportion right but the
rest right but the western right right
but let me just jump in there i mean
because another word to describe it as
we've seen on by the by western
countries as well as the united states
and nato is that they are in fact
describing this as an invasion
andre baklanov but let me put some of
what you had to say to
robert hunter over in washington uh your
response to the comment out of russia
and also let me just ask you this i mean
in january the u.s secretary of state
said that nato's door is open
it remains open and that is our
commitment knowing full well that this
is something that bothers russia
to what extent has this open door policy
maximized friction with russia
ambassador and as a result has
culminated in this current crisis
i can understand the concern in russia
about not having ukraine be a member of
nato which isn't going to happen
at the same time if you're talking about
1941 in operation barbarossa in which
the nazis went into the soviet union uh
the operation barbarossa now is being
conducted by russia against another
country and if there's any uh parallel
with the nazis uh it's in the kremlin
today ironically uh the
uh soviet union fought for two and a
half years uh to keep uh the nazis out
of the kremlin and now they're there in
the kremlin uh causing the causing
conflict there was no justification
whatsoever
for what russia is doing
nato no nato country uh not ukraine
which is not a nato country is posing
any threat whatsoever to russia mr putin
knows it he's for whatever reason
using forms of words to justify an
aggressive military action uh
unprecedented since since what the
russians call the great patriotic war
all right so if mr putin is concerned he
could just stop
uh negotiate and get everybody from
russia back out here's the thing here's
the thing let's just pause for a moment
the war in ukraine follows decades of
warnings that nato expansion into
eastern europe could actually provoke
russia and this is from the cia director
william j burns he'd been warning about
it since 1995 saying this hostility to
early nato expansion is almost
universally felt across the domestic
political spectrum here and when
president bill clinton's administration
moved to bring poland hungary and the
czech republic into nato he said the
decision was premature at best and
needlessly provocative at worst so there
have been warnings about this in the
past um brook stigner should we not be
surprised that things have gotten to
this point
well i'm not sure i fully agree with
that um
let's remember that when the sort of you
don't agree with that you don't agree
with the statement that was made by the
cia director which has been echoed in
fact by others including henry kissinger
in a 2014 opinion piece
of course so what but that doesn't mean
a journalist can contest it and i do
um for the following reason when the
soviet union fell apart and when the
warsaw pact fell apart let's remember
that these countries on their own chose
to join nato the way our russian speaker
has framed the issue is that it's as if
nature belligerently expanded eastward
it didn't there was a process
it's it's the path as we've heard nato
officials say over and over again it is
the democratic and independent choice of
each country to join the alliance these
countries asked to join if they weren't
interested in joining nato they wouldn't
have and or else
and then what you end up you end up with
a no man's land a strip of land running
down north south through europe which i
suppose russia would have liked to be
permanent
but these countries did not want that
permanent status they asked to join nato
you could you could argue that maybe
nato could have waited longer than 1997
to let them in another five or ten years
to massage relations with russia but on
the other hand there was a a lot of
pressure from these east european
capitals to join nato and perhaps they
had a reason for doing so
andre would you like to respond
yes first of all i'd like to underline
the fact which our friends in
united states are
ignoring
uh the
fact is that uh uh the present-day uh
government and uh the the rules of or in
in kiev they came
originally in in 2014
as a cool data illegal data this is the
first fact okay
kodata can happen but
it's for data a very specific nature
and uh
the the people now occupy and the key
positions they are
nazi so we think that a present day
campaign this is the prolongation of our
uh war which we had against the nazi
germany not in germany and they called
europe backed we don't uh we remember
that that all the europe were occupied
and the ruling shockers very willingly
helped
this
nazi germany and they made 60
of the necessary equipment for the
german uh aggressive army we remember
this
you know facts about the behavior of the
covert
i'd really like to keep the discussion
focused on today's events ambassador
robert hunter at weigh-in please because
i see you shaking your head
well if anybody is behaving like nazi
germany
uh today it's mr putin
i don't know whether he has a lot of
support in his own country but this is
an invasion of a sovereign country which
posed zero threat uh to russia or
anybody else nato has never invaded any
european country uh that
the russians could possibly care about
uh nato got involved in bosnia and
kosovo because of the incredibly bad
things that were happening there in fact
the russians supported
what nato and the west did in in bosnia
and then sent troops to the uh to the
implementation force but there was
absolutely no justification at all for
what russia is now doing but what do you
make of the arguments ambassador that
russia russia feels like its security is
in fact threatened because we have seen
activities in that particular region
such as war games with american tanks
staged in nearby baltic states we have a
rocket stage stationed in both poland
and romania and russia sees this as a
threat to its security
if you're asking me yes i am that
happened after the invasion
of crimea and the donbass region in 2014
and remember up until then
there has been the nato-russia founding
act
russia was involved in the council with
nato as an equal after brussels could
have continued that but instead mr putin
decided in 2014 to seize a chunk of
of of europe and uh that was uncalled
for unprovoked uh there is no threat
from nato nobody can possibly
call what anything nato has done as a
provocation uh to russia uh whatever mr
putin has in mind
that's only in his mind but he is an
aggressive state and one of the problems
that's coming out of this is there's no
western state including the united
states that will ever again be able to
deal with mr putin uh if russia wants to
have a healthy relationship
russia is going to have to take care of
its own leadership we're going to
discuss that also in a moment i'd like
to get your take on what happens next
but first
brooks tigner if you can just give us
some context to this because why would
nato want to move east in the first
place you know since uh 1997 14 more
countries have joined the alliance
mainly in the east
well it's not that nato one i repeat
what i said earlier it's not that nato
wanted to move east it's the fact that
there were countries in the eastern part
of europe that asked to join nato so
therefore there was an organic
expansion there was no great game plan
to uh all of a sudden expand nato's
entire frontier eastward it just
happened uh step by step
um
as for
as for some of these exercises that our
russian speakers refer to i mean robert
hunter had a point most of these
uh prior to 2014 crimea most of these
exercises were notified by both sides
quite diligently under the cfe the
conventional forces in europe
convention or treaty
so everyone knew what everyone was doing
but since then things have become much
more ambiguous as both sides try to
figure out what the other is doing uh
the notifications haven't taken place
certainly from the russian side
so um
you can interpret whether nato is having
more aggressive military exercises in
the east
uh as you like
but i will say for one other thing on
the propaganda front or at least on the
language that's coming out of russia too
to
characterize
ukraine's
political leadership as nazis and that
that russia needs to de-nazify ukraine
has been it's just outrageous it has
really inflamed most of the ukrainians i
know and it's a great irony to accuse
the country's president of being a nazi
when in fact i think mr zielinski
has lost family members
during during the holocaust and and and
in second world war so this isn't this
kind of language is not helping
relations at all andre baklanov uh the
secretary general of nato stoltenberg
has said that nato entering the fighting
in ukraine could lead to widespread war
in europe i mean looking ahead um
what is the view from russia about about
what happens
next in the coming days and weeks ahead
first of all i'd like to
to react a little bit for the sake of
for the sake of time for the sake of
time andrei baklanov i'd really
appreciate an answer to my question
let's look ahead and and tell me what
you think will happen
uh well actually we are very much uh you
know nervous about the mercenaries uh
coming uh from uh from europe they are
sending approximately 16
000 mercenaries uh
there and also new and new armaments
coming to the hands of these nazi
elements and uh the minister of foreign
affairs yesterday reacted uh to this uh
thing and they said that again and again
in 20th century and now in 21st century
german for instance are sending the uh
the uh armaments to kill russians but
what is putin what is putin's end game
what is putin's
what is putin's end game with the war in
ukraine
well actually
we uh we came to the point where it's
necessary to do something you you know
that in munich
a few weeks ago
the so-called president of ukraine he
claimed that ukraine will acquire
atomic weapons well we made uh
well
impossible for the united germany to
acquire this because we
uh in in in 1945
with all due respect he is the president
of ukraine he is the elected president
of ukraine so i don't think we can call
him the so-called president but let me
go over to robert hunter in washington
ambassador hunter just before we end the
show before we end the show just tell me
how you see this playing out
well that really is up to mr putin
because we have said in the west
beginning with the united states that we
will not get involved in this conflict
even though it is an aggressive action
against a sovereign country to which in
1994
russia along with britain and the united
states in exchange for
uh ukraine giving up nuclear weapons a
solemn commitment
to protect the border of ukraine not to
do anything against ukraine that's and
also to belarus into kazakhstan they
have broken that commitment no matter
what has happened on the western side uh
russia has put itself in a position of
an aggressor nation if mr putin wants to
stop now
arrangements can be worked out so that
as we tried back in the 1990s russia can
be a full participant in an overall
european security effort mr putin
decided he didn't want it and he has now
put himself in a situation where he's
damaged his country his country for a
long time to come short-term sanctions
are one thing long-term isolation from
the outside world he is damning his own
people uh to go through the terrible
deprivations they went through in the
cold war all right and final word over
to you brooks taken over there's been a
a lot of diplomatic activity where you
are in particular in brussels um
how how do how do nations uh sort of
dial back how does everybody dial back
from this and what how do you foresee
this playing out over the next days and
weeks ahead
well i don't think there will be much of
a way to thing to dial back things
diplomatically that's been the main
uh plea of
uh of the western nations uh which has
fallen on deaf ears in in moscow as for
the way as for how this might play out i
won't speculate about mr putin's end
game but i will speculate about his
tactics um it would make sense if he
cannot
conquer physically the entire country
that he would probably pull back and
hold the areas that he has
and then use the same tactics the same
approach that he did with the donbass uh
get the people in there and move some
people in there in order to support him
declare them as republics then absorb
the territories eventually into russia i
wouldn't be surprised if that was his uh
his plan
all right we'll leave it there thank you
so much for joining us brooks tigner
robert hunter and andre baklanov we
really appreciate your time with us
thank you for watching you can see the
program again anytime by visiting our
website aljazeera.com for further
discussion you can go to our facebook
page that's facebook.com forward slash
aj inside story join the conversation on
twitter our handle is aj inside story
myself and the whole team here in delhi
thanks for watching and bye bye for now
[Music]